so now when you do come against that
where your gut is telling you something
and the greater good or whoever it is is
saying I don't think so you just proceed
anyway
does that intuition whisper to you does
it yeah I'm pretty clear usually but
that comes from experience that's just
time you know doing it again and again
and again and again and it's a
case-by-case situation you know there's
there's a lot of very sensible advice
out there saying for example not to
launch production on quantum theory my
current project to begin with because
female-driven science fiction is not how
it's done I mean you know that being a
woman in the industry you I'm sure heard
a million reasons why you can't Edline a
movie with a woman I've got to
we have gay characters in this movie
that are not being pointed out as gay
they're not gay they're not gay in a
demonstrative way you don't mean they're
not gay ultimately the point is that it
is not what's the word propaganda either
pro or con you know I'm saying and and
even even in very friendly shows today
you put a character that is in any way a
minority and that and the tendency is to
is to choose a propagandistic angle for
that character and make a statement and
these are just people you know and
that's something I think that that goes
against the grain of what people think
an audience is willing to accept and I
take that information into account I'm
not speaking studio financing for this
movie because I don't think it would
hold up under the studio system but we
are communicating with the audience and
they do like it and we are building the
tools to put this movie in theaters it's
all about the right tool for the right
job if you want to work with the studio
give them what they want because they're
your audience if you're selling
screenplays to Paramount Paramount's
your audience right what paramount likes
you know be honest with yourself about
what your goals are my goal right now is
to please the audience that we started
building with this
mine record and to please ourselves and
to build on the onset relationships that
we built on the star mine record and
turn it into something more and turn
into something good it comes with a
different set of business criteria so
ultimately for that goal
quantum theory is the perfect tool I
have a million other screenplays that I
can recommend for somebody who finds it
unlikely to succeed it will succeed
we've got the tools it's happening right
now you know and and and you know in
terms of financing it's just a question
of finding the person who who is
prepared to succeed on the terms that we
are prepared to succeed on it almost
makes me think of the character and
brave how they felt that she wasn't
princess-like enough she didn't want to
be a girly girl and she was too fiercely
independent no and so they labeled her
as maybe she was gay but they didn't say
it and so it seemed like she had to fit
into a box of some sort I think that's
what you learn back talking about in
terms of like identifying the characters
like okay this is the one person here
this is this person you know ah good
question well I think I think there's
two different ways to look at it at the
problem there's a very utilitarian
perspective and there's a very these are
the rules and we and the rules are there
for a reason perspective which they are
at the end of the day if you're doing
business with a major studio you're
doing business largely with people who
did not come from the entertainment
industry and who do not view this as a
performance enterprise they view it as a
product enterprise first and foremost
and they've learned the rules of
manufacturing products and ultimately
they create these different categories
to put products in because you have to
have an inventory like that's how they
think and there's nothing wrong with
that the studios are doing very well and
they're getting very smart about how
they manage it to they're smarter now
than they were before buying Marvel was
a great move for Disney by Pixar was a
great move for Disney they've been
brilliant about how they have managed
how they identify
and target products because they are
buying people who have been in the
throes of that industry for a long time
and who understand who understand how
the audience sees it may be a little
more comprehensively you know and and I
am and you're seeing the same thing in
other companies you've got companies
like Universal buying up focus features
smart move Universal you know and that's
what happens when when when it when it
when a publicly traded corporation
reaches a certain size they have to stop
making products and start buying
companies because making products is too
risky to reach the investors that
haven't already bought their stock it's
all about supply and demand
you gotta find more people to buy the
stock after 10 million people have
bought your stock you got to be think a
little outside the box about how you're
gonna get the next 10 you got to change
something you don't I mean so so if
you're talking to those people and
you're trying to please those people
which is fine I will gladly have that
conversation if anybody from universals
watching and you're like wow this kids
pretty smart can I buy a screenplay from
him the answer is yes you may please
call you know and I'll do whatever you
need me to do and I will make it
excellent I will play by your rules and
I will play by your rules exquisitely I
will be your David Beckham you know but
those rules are there because the system
needs them to be not because the
audience needs them to be and and
preserving the system is how those guys
get paid so it's very important that
they continue to do it it and so I don't
want to talk about how that works in a
way that minimizes its importance
because to some people it's hugely
important and not it's not BS it's not
you know it's it's a little I think
naive for a young upcoming filmmaker to
be like screw it well
yes cool and you could make a hundred
thousand dollars in two months if you
play your cards right and that will help
you
you know so so you know so there's that
but on the flip side of it you know my
experience in the performing arts has
always been in theater and you can't
ignore the audience when you're on stage
I'm not at the end of the day built for
pleasing the system I built for pleasing
the people and communicating with them
as an ensemble has been ultimately the
business practice that has driven a
Repertory Theater since before the days
of Shakespeare it's tried and true it's
a trend it is a market trend and it's a
far more long-standing market trend than
comic-book movies make money by a factor
of tens you know we're talking about
hundreds and thousands of years here
Homer built his freakin success on the
basis of that simple practice and people
are still reading his stuff today so for
me it really just boils down to what are
the specific goals of your production
what are you trying to achieve what are
the tools a screenplay as a tool a cast
as a tool
you know production teams are tools what
tools are you are going to most
effectively realize the goal that you
have set in front of yourself you know
and for me eight-sided films as a whole
all of us are a tool to please the
audience that likes the same things that
we do that's it so every decision that
goes into that is going to be focused I
mean the first the smell test is does it
do that does it help us get fun projects
that they're going to like or
challenging projects that whatever is it
going to help us get a film out there
that they're gonna love yes or no you
know and working by the studio's rules
right now in this case will not help us
achieve that it's just not it it's not
more doing right now you know but if
somebody comes at me with a great plan
and I can make some money doing that
then I don't turn on a dime
I'll sell right out
but I won't sell out eight-sided films
because that's not what it's for
you